foreign
is a machine learning framework used for
image classification and neural network
processing by dots is a python based
open source machine learning
implementation based on the torch
Library it is one of the most popular AI
Library among industry and academic
researchers worldwide hey everyone you
are already watching simply learn and in
today's video we're going to be learning
all about what is pytots if you love
watching videos like this do hit the
Subscribe button to never miss any
updates from Simply love if you want to
become a deep learning expert consider
deep learning with kairas and tensorflow
by simplica and master those necessary
skills check out the link in the
description for more details before we
get started further I have one simple
question for you guys
which is an open source machine learning
library for python that is entirely
based on Torch and the options are
tensor pie torch numpy or python if you
know the answer please leave them in the
comment box below and now let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session
first let's start with what is pi torch
falling to that how does pie touch work
then Pi dots features moving ahead let
us know by touch benefits and finally
the use cases of Pi torch
so now let's start with what is pi torch
pytots is a free and open source Python
and torch machine learning
implementation deep learning models
based on neural networks are currently
being developed and trained in a variety
of deep learning projects using pytots
because of its ease of use pytorch is
increasingly being used to create
artificial neural network models pytos
is used by data scientists for
artificial intelligence research and
applications
next we have how does pie torch work
to write readable code pytotech adhes to
Python's distinct and unique coding
features it allows developers to run and
test the relevant portions of code
immediately rather than waiting for the
entire program to finish furthermore it
eliminates the need for neural network
debuggers machine learning programmers
and deep learning researchers to run the
code in real time without having to wait
to see if it works or not
now we know what pytorch is and it's
working so moving ahead let's understand
the features of Pi torch
few mentioned python features are simple
interference tools and libraries tensor
computation Dynamic graph computation
variables parameters modules and
functions so let's understand each in
detail
so let python python has a
straightforward user interference it
offers a simple way to use the
application programming interference API
the Python's framework is very simple to
use and run
next we have tools and libraries
it is possible to expand Pi torch and
support development in fields like
computer vision and reinforcement
learning by using a wide range of tools
and libraries
next
tensor computation
tensor computation with row burst GPU
graphical Processing Unit acceleration
support equivalent to numpy next
Dynamic graph computation
dynamic graphs are adaptable and let us
examine and change the internals of the
graph at any time the dynamic graph in
Phi torch is used it follows from our
Declaration of variables that the
computational graph is constructed
dynamically so following each training
iterations the graphics rebuilt
next we have variables
for the purpose of holding the gradient
the variables is enclosed outside the
tensor a computational graphs node is
represented by it
next we have parameters
parameters encircle variables they are
used when using a parameter as a tensor
which isn't possible when using a
variable is required
and next comes module
stateful computation module serves as
their building blocks in order to
simplify and facelates this creation of
complex multi-layer neural network
pytots offers a large library of models
next
we have functions
the connections between the two
variables are as follows functions don't
have their memory and don't have any
memory to store the state or a buffer
moving ahead we have five touch benefits
because it syntax and usage is similar
to python it makes development simple
for python developers to learn and
understand
it has an easy to use interference and
straightforward python coding
it includes a large number of libraries
and well-known tools that make debugging
easier then scalability strong support
on well-known Cloud platform and a small
open source focused communities are all
available next let's have a look at the
use cases of Pi torch the Python's
framework is well known for being
convenient and adaptable with example of
its more typical use cases including
reinforcement learning image
classification and neural language
processing so let's learn each in detail
the development of Robotics for
Automation and using pytorch in business
strategy plan to benefit from
reinforcement learnings quick and
flexible experimentation capabilities
with powerful GPU acceleration pytouch
makes sensors and dynamic neural
networks available RL machines are
designed to learn from experience to
make wise decision and obtain the best
rewards next we have image
classification
pytouch employs an image classification
algorithm that requires developers to
categorize an image based on its visual
content
a computer vision application for
example can use an algorithm to
determine whether a given image contain
an object such as a car or bicycle
object detection is simple for the human
eye but difficult for computer vision
application
next is natural language processing
NLP is a technology the main component
of NLP are speed recognition optical
character recognition Mission
translation and information retrieval
computers can comprehend spoken and
written languages with the help of NLP
technology
and with that we come to the end of this
video what is pytotch if you like this
video share it with your friends before
I sign off make sure you subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to get
all the updates we'll be back with more
such interesting videos until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here